popularity of that event it seems that
many politicians
watched the match i didn't but boris
johnson was at an event in his own
garden
danny street he watched it on the screen
there he of course isn't really a
football fan makes no bones about it but
he's released pictures and videos
well he might if they win uh well there
is a
notable history of football and
politicians trying to
get some advantage from it kirsten is a
genuine football fan he was at wembley
last night he's already released one
statement about it so i'm sure he'll try
again
and what do you think i mean it goes all
the way back to harold wilson in the
1960s
if the england football team does well
does it help the government of the day
god knows probably not i mean look i
think there is a sense in which boris
johnson is a lucky general
with many many different uh uh things of
his uh premiership where can't seem to
fall in his
uh in in his in his lap but i'm not sure
that
uh as long as prime ministers don't uh
say something silly then it particularly
benefits them
uh but prime ministers leaders of the
opposition always trying to look like
they're on the right side of public
opinion possibly
it doesn't really matter he's taking his
seat now
and just a few words from uh silency
ohio the speaker before it all starts
but i think you're right sam i'm pretty
sure
uh the first words when the prime
minister describes his day
will be congratulations to the football
team i'm sure they've been great
in october 1993 having served in the
army across the world for 24 years
which included the overseeing of a field
hospital in northern saudi arabia
during the first gulf war under his
retirement
as band sergeant major in the scots
guards
ian a gifted musician who plays the
french horn
and violin came to the commons to be a
senior door keeper around the chamber
he joined speaker michael martin's team
in my office in 2001
as the train bearer which is how he is
dressed today
before the promotion to the assistant
secretary to the speaker in 2011
which is the role he has held until now
ian's military discipline his can do
attitude his friendship his sense of
humor
expertise will be solely missed by my
team and particularly by me
i've got to say it's not an easy job to
become speaker
but the one thing we was knowing that
ian davis was there to advise me
and the speaker secretary and i cannot
thank ian enough
for the support and the help that he's
given me personally as well as the
office
and of course ian wasn't the scots
guards so was his father so he's got a
great history
in serving this country after 52 years
of public
service and then be for services to
parliament
ian i would like to wish you all the
best and a very happy retirement with
linda
back home on the isle of wight the other
white's game is the commons lost
thank you for everything
[Applause]
before we get underway i would like to
point out the british sign language
interpretation of the prime minister's
questions available to watch on the
parliament live tv
now we come to preston's requirement
prime minister catherine fletcher
it's the number one mr speaker thank you
mr speaker can i
can i begin by echoing and supporting
very much your
fine tribute to ian davis and to thank
him for all his service to this house
and
uh wish him all the very best in his
retirement
and mr speaker i know members from
across this house
will want to congratulate gareth
southgate and his team
on their 2-0 win against germany at
wembley last night the first time the
men's team
have beaten germany in 55 years in a
knockout game
we wish them all the best for their
match against ukraine
on saturday and we'll all be hoping
against hope that this time
finally uh football is coming home mr
speaker
this morning i had meetings with
minister or colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house
i shall have further substitute such
meetings later today
mr speaker after yesterday's game many
of our german friends are
heading home but does my right
honourable friend agree that
as the sun goes if they want to stay
here drinking all our beer
then they need to join the 5.6 million
people who have already successfully
applied for the uss settlement scheme
uh forthwith before today's deadline
[Music]
yes mr speaker i thank my honorable
friend and she is absolutely right
i am thrilled that an astonishing 5.6
million
uh eu nationals have already applied for
this uh wonderful scheme
and i encourage anybody who is still
eligible
to submit their obligations today we
don't come to the leader of the
opposition
kia stammer thank you mr speaker can i
join your
um comments and sentiments about ian
davis and wishing the very best
from all of us in this house can i also
congratulate the
england team um for yesterday's
performance having been at wembley for
the euro 96 semi-final
an experienced first half the agony of
that defeat yesterday's result was truly
um incredible and i know the whole house
will wish the team
the very best of luck on saturday the
whole house uh we'll wish them the best
of luck
on saturday i'm sure mr speaker
why didn't the prime minister sack the
former health secretary on friday
morning
mr speaker uh we had a i read the story
in common with
uh you and everybody else on on friday
and we had a new health secretary in
place by
saturday uh mr speaker which i think
given that we
given that we have a pandemic i think
uh to move from one health structure
next uh with that
uh speed uh was was fast mr speaker but
it wasn't as fast
as the vaccine rollout mr speaker
which is which is now going so fast that
we've done
in this week half of the under 30s half
of the under 30s mr speaker
have now had their first jab and that
is speed
mr speaker what a ridiculous answer the
price the prime minister must have been
the only person in the country who
looked at that photo on friday morning
and thought that the health centre
shouldn't be sacked immediately
on friday the prime minister
spokesperson said quote
the prime minister considers the mata
closed
minister after minister were then sent
out to defend the indefensible
it was brief that the prime minister was
quite happy
for the health center to stay in his
post so
can the prime minister clarify now he's
got the chance did he sack the health
secretary or at any point
ask him to resign yes or no
by comparison the right honourable
gentleman opposite who spent three days
trying and failing uh to to sack his
deputy leader
uh who he then who he then promoted
who he then promoted mr speaker he fires
and rehires
mr speaker the deputy leader is sitting
beside me the former the former health
secretary
the former health secretary has done a
runner
oh mr speaker on friday the prime
minister said the case
was closed then on monday he tried to
take the credit for the health sectors
resigning
in a minute he'll be telling us he
scored the winner last night
but let me press the promise a bit more
on this the person the health secretary
was in a relationship
with was his non-executive director
let me remind the house according to the
government's own
guidance one of the roles of a
non-executive director
is to challenge the secretary of state
and the department to challenge them
and they receive taxpayers money for
doing so
so from the offset it was blindingly
obvious that there was a conflict of
interest here
and a whole host of unanswered questions
why on earth
did the prime minister judge that this
matter was closed on friday morning
mr speaker i hesitate to accuse the
right of
a repeating expression i observe that
the non-executive directory question
is also uh no longer uh with the
department and what the what the
continuity mr speaker
is that that department is getting on
with the fastest vaccine rollout
of any uh of any european country and
i'm
proud to tell uh this house that uh this
week what does that tell you what's
happened just in the last few days
uh this country has actually overtaken
israel
in the proportion of people we have
vaccinated mr speaker
and i think he might pay tribute to the
health department for that achievement
yes so mr speaker let me get this right
the prime minister was happy to keep a
health threat in place during the
pandemic
who he not only thought was absolutely
hopeless
but he also you had broken the rules and
was in a relationship with somebody he
was employing at taxpayers expense
it doesn't sound like case closed to me
and i know the prime minister is keen to
sweep this under the carpet
but let me tell the prime minister why
this matters
millions of people made huge and very
difficult sacrifices
to follow the rules that his health
secretary had introduced
prime minister take the case of ollie
bibi
i'm sorry you might want to listen ollie
died of leukemia
on the 5th of may the day before the
photo of the former health secretary was
taken
ollie died like so many other people in
this pandemic
with his family and friends unable to
spend time with him
when he was in hospital he begged to see
his family but following the rules
only one member of his family was
allowed to see him
his mum said i'm livid
we did everything we were told to do and
the man who made the rules didn't
how can that be right so i asked the
prime minister again how could he
possibly think
this matter was closed on friday morning
mr speaker we all share the grief and
the pain of ollie and his family
and millions of people up and down the
country who have endured the privations
uh that this country has been through in
order to get the chronovirus pandemic
under control and that is why uh we had
a change of health secretary
the day after the story appeared uh mr
speaker and that is why
actually what we are doing as a
government instead of focusing on
stuff going on within the westminster
bubble we are focusing on
rolling out that vaccine those vaccines
at
a rate that will make sure that
people like olly and his family do not
have to suffer in the future and i'm
proud to say
as a result of the efforts as a result
of the efforts made by
the nhs by the department of health by
july
the 19th we will have vaccinated
everybody every adult over 18
would have received one jab and
everybody over 40
would have received two jabs mr speaker
that is the priority of this government
and quite right
[Music]
mr speaker i can hardly think
that the prime minister thinks it's
appropriate in response to a question
about olly
to suggest that this is in his words the
westminster bubble
the westminster bubble in answer to that
question prime minister
before prime minister's questions this
morning i spoke to olly's mum
about the awful circumstances that she
and her family have been through
she told me prime minister that every
day she watched the press conferences
every day they were on and she hung on
to every word
that government said so that she would
know what her family could and couldn't
do
and then they followed the rules this is
not the westminster bubble
she told me that for her and her family
this case
isn't closed and she speaks for millions
of people
ask the prime minister withdraw that
when he gets up
withdraw that when he gets up it is a
it's the wrong response
to olly's case i can't help concluding
that the prime minister didn't ask
relevant questions on friday morning
either because he didn't want to know
the answers or because he knows full
well there's more to come out
yes well then he says nonsense
so i asked the prime minister in
response to his muttered nonsense
when he declared the case closed on
friday morning had he asked the health
secretary
if he'd broken any other rules yes or no
mr speaker let me be absolutely clear
with the right origin uh
and i think the whole house the whole
country can see that we have a new
health secretary
in place and i've had one since the day
after the stories appeared and that was
entirely right
and that it was and that was the that
was the right response to the
to the situation and he is of course
he's right in what he says about the
the sacrifice made by by families up and
down
the land but the best response in my
view to
their grief and their pain and the
sufferings that they have endured
is which is which is is to get on
uh with a new health secretary which is
what we have and
to with all the energy and application
uh that we have
to roll out those vaccines and allow the
people of this country
to work forwards towards freedom day
which i devoutly hope will come
on july the 19th and never let it be
forgotten mr speaker
that if we followed the advice of the
right honourable gentleman that would
not be possible because it was under his
proposal that we would have stayed in
the european
medicines agency and been unable unable
to deliver the vaccine rollout at all
yes speaker i really think that having
failed to sack the former health sector
he really is trying to take credit now
for the fact that we've got a new health
secretary so mr speaker mr speaker
well he would it wouldn't be there if
the prime minister had his way the
matter was closed
so mr speaker it's no questions asked by
the prime minister on friday
but no questions answered today there's
a pattern here
when dominic cummings broke the rules by
driving to barnard castle
the prime minister backed him when the
when the housing secretary
unlawfully approved a billion pound
property deal for a tory donor
the prime minister backed him when the
home certainly broke the minister of
code
the prime minister backed her and when
the health secretary broke covert rules
the prime minister tried and wanted to
back him
to every time it's the same old story
isn't it the case mr speaker that while
the british people are doing
everything asked of them it's one rule
for them
and another rule for everybody else
mr speaker this gov there was a new
health secretary the following day
mr speaker now the whole country the
whole country can see that and we are
getting on
we are getting on uh with our agenda of
vaccinating
the population of this country through
the energy and application
of uh of the new secretary of state for
health and the department of health and
i thank them and i
and i congratulate as a result of that
that vaccine rollout mr speaker which as
i say
uh would have been which would have been
impeded fatally impeded
how we followed the part the policies of
the party opposite
uh that we're able uh now to we have a
higher
wall of vaccination than virtually any
other country in the world and we are
able to proceed
with our cautious but we hope
irreversible unlocking
of the uk economy uh with the result mr
speaker
that growth is up to levels we haven't
seen since last july
jobs are up i mean we cause it he calls
for us to he calls for us to act faster
in
in removing cabinet ministers mr speaker
it took him three days as i say
to give her three new jobs three new
jobs
shadow chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster a shadow secretary of state
for the future of work we create jobs mr
speaker
he creates non-jobs he gives we deliver
jacob thank you thank you mr speaker
the steel industry is an asset of
national strategic
importance not just my words but the
words of the prime minister
and i know he means it because when
grebel went into administration
this government supported british steel
until a new buyer was
found british steel still employed more
than 800 people in red cross cleveland
and more than 3 000 people in scunthorpe
so can i ask the prime minister
in light of the tra's recommendations to
the trade secretary
how will he ensure that steele remains a
national strategic asset
[Music]
my honorable friend is absolutely right
to campaign for british steel
and we have an ambitious plan to uh
transform our country with better use
of british steel as as i said to the
house a couple of weeks ago there's a
7.6 million
pipeline of steel uh waiting to be uh
used over there waiting to be
uh bought over the next decade and as
for the
recommendations of the uh trade remedies
authority
uh the government is considering them
and the department for international
trade
will update the house later today leader
of the smp ian blackman
yeah thank you mr speaker can i join you
in wishing that ian davis all the best
for his
retirement and thank him for the service
that he's given to the
scots guards in this house he has truly
been a
friend and a sane voice to give guidance
to those of us on these benches when
we've
needed it and i thank him very much for
that can i
congratulate england for their victory
last night and of course
wish them all the best in the tournament
ahead
of course they've done well they've won
most of their matches with the exception
of the game against scotland where of
course they even failed to score a goal
knee lock but mr speaker in july
2019 this prime minister gave an
unequivocal guarantee to eu nationals
living in the uk the prime minister said
they will have an absolute certainty for
the right to
live and remain less than two years
later
hundreds of thousands of eu nationals
have been left in limbo including
thousands of children while the
settlement scheme deadline
falls today we know there are hundreds
of thousands
of unprocessed cases it is simply
unacceptable mr speaker
that their rights will be diminished by
their failures of this government
will the prime minister honor his word
give certainty scrap the disastrous
settle status deadline
before we face another tory windrush
i thank the right honourable gentleman
and i i'm
just repeat what i said to my honorable
friend earlier i think it's fantastic
that 5.6 million people uh have uh
applied
uh we are processing all the
applications as fast as we as we
possibly can
and clearly the most important thing is
for anybody who still hasn't
applied to get their application in
today in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker but the issue is
there is a backlog of hundreds of
thousands of cases
because of delays on decisions mr
speaker overnight
thousands of our friends and neighbours
could become illegal immigrants
they're living in fears for their jobs
their families
and their livelihoods all because this
prime minister would keep his word
we know all too well the experience of
this government's home office
dawn raids vulnerable people deported
a hostile environment for the windrush
generation
scotland's message to eu citizens is
you're welcome here
we want you to stay this is your home
but this uk government is causing eu
citizens
untold stress one woman who has been in
the uk for 44 years
says that she feels suicidal another
says she feels like a third-rate
citizen so mr speaker this is shameful
will the government now do the right
thing scrap the deadline and introduce
automatically granted settle status or
will the prime minister's legacy be
the ridiculous removal of nha staff our
local community workers
our teachers and many more who have made
their homes here
yeah mr speaker it's obvious from the
statistics i've already quoted that this
is an
outstanding success because we've had
huge numbers of people
applying and of course if there are
people still
who have to apply that there's been
several extensions of the data it's five
years now
uh since the brexit uh referendum uh
we've
we've funded uh 72 organizations to help
vulnerable
uh eu citizens to understand what their
rights are to make uh the applications
uh anybody applying within the deadline
will of course have their
have their case dealt with and i urge
them to get on with it
let's go to henry smith henry
thank you very much mr speaker i pay
tribute to the government for the world
leading
kovid 19 vaccination program and can i
encourage my write-and-go friend
and the government to press ahead with
allowing those who are fully vaccinated
greater international travel to save as
many
aviation and travel sector jobs as
possible and help
regrow our economy
i i thank my honorable friend and i i
congratulate him on his
a long-standing campaign for the
unjustified campaign for the aviation
sector and uh that's why we've invested
seven
uh billion pounds already uh to support
aviation since the start
of the of the pandemic but obviously
what we hope is that the vaccine
rollout program the double jabs program
will enable people
to start flying and really give that uh
industry the prospect of a long term
sustainable recovery let's go to
caroline lucas caroline
thank you mr speaker today the
environmental audit committee of which
i'm a member
has published a report calling for
transformational change
in the government's approach to
restoring nature and it's not just about
the 15 percent of uk species that are
threatened with extinction
the cuckoos the kitty wakes the turtle
doves but the ebbing away of so much of
our natural world
the conservative chair of our committee
says that government policies too often
remain and i quote
grandiose statements lacking teeth and
devoid of effective delivery mechanisms
so i want to ask the prime minister
something very specific
will he look again at the government
amendment to the environment bill
that refers only to measures to further
the objective of halting species decline
rather than actually meeting that
objective a one-word
change from furthering to meeting would
make a world of difference by
introducing the legally binding target
to halt biodiversity loss by 2030 but
his government has promised
so will he do it will he make that
change yes or no
mr speaker this government is is
committed not just to halting
uh but to reversing biodiversity loss
not just in this country
but around the world and she can see
that from the conclusions of the
of the g7 summit and everything that the
government does uh to promote
biodiversity across our country
thank you speaker over the last few
years we've seen the proliferation
of hate speech harmful content
anti-vaccine conspiracy theories on
social media
in response the government has published
its world-leading draft
online safety bill can the prime
minister say when parliament will be
given the opportunity to start the
scrutiny of that draft bill
prime minister uh the uh bill's been
published in
uh draft form and a pre-legislative
scrutiny uh will start as
soon as a joint committee has been
established and i'm given to understand
uh from my right old friend the chief
whip that uh my my rival friend may be
in a position
uh to serve uh with advantage in the
scrutiny of that bill
catherine mckinnon thank you
we all know that great sport starts at
the grassroots
whether that's football or swimming and
we all need help and encouragement to
live healthier lives post pandemic
yet since last march over 400 leisure
and fitness facilities
have permanently closed including our
much-loved
swimming pool in west denton and many
thousands more
are under threat so will the prime
minister do two things about that today
expand and extend the national level
leisure recovery fund
to fund these much needed facilities
and back newcastle's bid for the outer
west
leisure center from the leveling up fund
everybody deserves a chance to live a
healthier life
and one day perhaps to play or swim
for their country well i
i thank the honorable lady because i
think that uh it was a great question
and she's
absolutely right to champion grassroots
sport and what it can do for
uh for young people and for and for the
health of this country
uh i i certainly hope that uh the uh the
center she she champions will
uh be successful in uh in the leveling
up fun but obviously i can't
uh control that myself she must make
that case herself but
i'm wishing her every possible good
fortune
thank you mr speaker in rochester we are
incredibly proud of our long-standing
creative arts community and the
contribution it makes for the medway
towns
so it has come as a huge blow that the
board of directors at the university of
creative arts
have decided to close the rochester
campus after its 135 year history in the
town
having inspired some of our most
successful artists and designers
such as damesandra rhodes cara millen
and tracey emin
does my right honourable friend agree
that the university's plan
to close the site at such a difficult
time for the sector
will be detrimental to our leveling up
agenda locally
but also to the opportunities for so
many working class kids
in medway for who this campus has always
provided
an instrumental route into further and
higher education
i i thank my honourable friend she's
she's right to a campaign for
uh for higher education particularly in
her constituency
and i know that she's been engaged with
university leaders on
on the ground in uh in rochester and i'm
sure that they will have listened
carefully to what she has to say thank
you very much mr scott on friday i
visited
david mccutchen the chief executive of
billy express which is a haulage farm
in the bay scenario of my constituency
everybody in this house knows that there
have been
huge problems with a shortage of hgv
drivers in this country and that's only
been compounded further by brexit
so i've got a simple question for the
prime minister why can't we add hdb
drivers
to the uk shortage occupation list
mr speaker i'll certainly look at uh
what he's proposing but i think the most
important thing is to is to get our
entire workforce
back at work and there are currently uh
millions of people still on
uh still on furlough and uh and lately
of course there are labor shortages
at the moment but we need to get people
back into work and that's why we've got
to continue
to roll out the vaccines in the way that
we are let's go
to segura street garrett
uh thank you mr speaker my right
honourable friend will be aware that the
counties of cornwall devon somerset and
dorset have come together to form the
great south west
to generate regional growth and
prosperity in much the same way as the
midland engine and the northern
powerhouse
it has the support of all local
authorities laps and the business
community
but we've now been waiting for
recognition from government
for well over three years and
frustration mr speaker is reaching
fever pitch can my writer befriend
please look into this matter
and give us the green light so we can
help the government achieve its
objectives of sustainable growth
prosperity and jobs
mr speaker i i'm a a passionate
supporter of the
of the greater south west and the
prospects that it
uh it brings but i understand also that
uh uh
the right honourable friend has has met
the minister for regional growth
and local government to discuss these
proposals and i look forward to hearing
uh their outcome let's go to christina
ruiz christina
thank you mr speaker many of my
constituents have been angered by the
treatment of
dvla staff on the disgraceful harassment
of pcs union rep sarah evans
with cases rising significantly in south
wales in the third wave of the pandemic
why does the prime minister feel it is
so acceptable
for the dvla to have returned over 450
staff to their swansea sites contrary to
government advice
as some of them can and have been
working effectively and safely from home
mr speaker as i understand it uh rates
of infection and
uh disease have been declining at the
dvla
site and i very much that uh
uh everybody there can i return to work
in the normal way
as soon as possible tom mr speaker the
high streets had a
difficult time lately and uh deadlines
have been no exception but fiddling
buried council's leveling up fund bid
will help to kick-start high street
regeneration improve
our new town centre and encourage
healthy travel
in netherfield so all my writing will
find joining me in thanking the council
officers
uh at golden boy council particularly
mike hill and joel davis have put the
book together
and really agree with me that this is a
bid that can help to make good living an
even better place
to live work and raise a family
[Music]
yes mr speaker i thank mike hill and
joelle davis for their efforts and uh
that's exactly
and i thank them also for what they're
doing to uh
to uh call upon the the leveling up fund
uh which will indeed invest in
infrastructure uh projects that includes
that improves uh life in across the
country but
any acro in his constituency
particularly
let's go to dr philippa whitford
philippa
thanks very much mr speaker due to his
failure to maintain
strict border quarantine and delay in
adding india to the red list
cases of the delta variant are surging
across the uk
as well as a marked regional variation
the biggest ongoing
impact is on sectors such as hospitality
entertainment and aviation so rather
than starting to reduce
financial support from tomorrow will the
prime minister agree
to extend full furlough and business
support beyond september
particularly for those geographical
areas and businesses
which are most affected
no mr speaker because although the
delta variant is is indeed seeded and
growing in
at least 74 countries around the world
uh
including this one this is the only
country or the the country where the
protection
uh by immunity against the delta variant
is the highest and
uh and the strongest and that's why
we're going to continue uh with our
cautious but irreversible roadmap and
i hope that it will command our support
let's go to peter gibson peter
thank you mr speaker can i thank my
right honourable friend for all that he
is doing to level up our country
a rising tide must float all ships
and to that end will he commit to
delivering the northern link road for
darlington
and will he further commit to helping
stop lner's
great train robbery of services from our
station
and finally does my right honourable
friend agree with me
that our leveling up agenda investing in
the north
should provide the people of battley and
spain with great confidence as they go
to the polls
prime minister yes mr speaker and uh he
tells you all you need to know about the
modern
uh labour party that when they heard
that there was going to be an economic
campus in darlington
they called it giving up mr speaker
that's what that's what the right
honourable gentleman said and
he's totally right uh by the way to
support uh ryan stevenson in his
campaign
uh for battley and spend uh tomorrow i
believe that ryan will offer a strong
local voice for change and progress in
battling spam
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the prime
minister is delighted
that the high court in belfast this
morning upheld the government's view
on the northern ireland protocol and
later today we're also expecting a joint
a eu uk agreement in relation to
extension of the grace period
around chilled meats so does the prime
minister accept that today may well be a
watershed
where we can stop talking about the
protocol in constitutional and identity
terms
but rather the uk and eu jointly work
through the genuine problems to find
pragmatic solutions
and in doing so can the prime minister
also call for calm in northern ireland
ahead of the marching season
yes mr speaker and the best thing that
the uh the eu can
do is to make sure that we remove uh all
the problems that currently
uh associated with the their application
of the protocol
uh the ban on uh until meets the the
restriction on the circulation of cancer
drugs
uh the fact that twenty percent of all
the customs checks carried out around
the whole of the eu
are carried out on uh in northern
ireland uh
and i hope that all that can be fixed uh
indeed mr speaker and then uh we can
move on
thank you mr speaker yesterday i was in
batley and spend campaigning with our
fantastic candidate ryan stevenson
he is committed to delivering the police
that we need on our streets
so from brixton to sulcum bat lita
batley and spen
will the prime minister commit to
supporting initiatives like the
councillor advocate scheme that was
launched by my police and crime
commissioner alison hernandez
yes i am a big fan of alison hernandez
mr speaker and i i think she's doing
absolutely the
the right thing and uh to support her we
are of course
increasing uh policing presence on the
streets of
uh the city we're rolling up county
lines drugs gangs about a third of them
uh that we've tackled uh so far and uh
we've also instituted
tougher penalties for serious uh sexual
and violent offenders mr speaker which
were opposed on a three-line whip by the
party opposite
bill ribeiro abbey thank you mr speaker
um we're experiencing a knife crime
epidemic
in london as much as 50 people have been
killed by knife crime in our city with a
staggering 17 of these
being young people and one of my own
young constituents
i fear that we are going to see more
people young people in particular
needlessly lose their lives and with the
summer approaching more and more
violence
on our streets the prime minister is
aware just how much youth services
are important in the prevention of of
crime so could he explain
why his government has cut over 70
percent of youth services in the past
decade
and will he pledge to do more for this
city's young people
put his money where his mouth is and
reverse
these disastrous cuts
mr speaker we invested in youth services
and we'll continue to and will continue
to
continue to do so but i think it's quite
extraordinary
that uh she continues to avoid the the
macavity-like performance of the mayor
of london
uh who totally who is totally failing to
to grip this
uh to reduce a serious crime and to stop
knife crime
there was a previous mayor of london uh
mr speaker who got the murder rate down
by fifty percent
uh because we because we gripped it and
we took responsibility
in city hall i think it's shocking uh to
see what city khan
uh is doing on on this issue but we will
do everything we can
to fill in the gap impairs the final
question uh thank you
uh mr speaker and can i uh refer to my
registered interests and also associate
all northern ireland members with the
tribute you've made to ian davies
today prime minister today the belfast
high court has actually found that the
protocol
does conflict with the act of union
though does not break the law
that it is repealed aspects of the
active union which is in direct
contravention
to the commitments that this government
has actually made to the people
of this kingdom he will be the prime
minister will be aware that litigation
is still ongoing
in the high court in england on a
commercial case that could result in the
loss of earnings
claim of hundreds of millions of pounds
by british
businesses trading in northern ireland
under section 8 of the withdrawal
agreement
the parliament here is sovereign
the judgement today confirms that
parliament is sovereign
prime minister you have a solid majority
on your benches have you the will to now
finish this job to reverse the mistakes
of the northern ireland protocol to
seize the moment
and to defend the union and to
unilaterally fix
once and for all and put northern
ireland out of its commercial
social and political misery minister
thank you mr speaker i i thank the uh
honourable general we will of course
study the
uh the ruling of the court uh in detail
uh but i can give him this general
assurance which he knows to be
true that nothing uh will affect the
position
of northern ireland as part of the
united kingdom and we will make sure
that we uphold that
i'm now suspending the house for three
minutes to enable the necessary resumes
to be made for the next business order
coming up going to be an urgent question
on the question of
uh protocols relating to kovid in
schools uh
prime minister's questions as we were
predicting uh the main
party leaders kiestarma asked questions
about the departure of matt hancock
and the scottish national party
spokesperson
concentrated on eu citizens in this
country
who must register by today let's get
the thoughts i definitely related to sam
coates uh
interesting looking at social media
contrasting views really as to who came
out best on matt hancock
that's right we've got um uh kiss
diamond going as we expected
on on matt hancock making the allegation
that uh boris johnson should have sacked
him earlier
ultimately question got the outcome that
he wanted matt hancock's know it
no longer at his job so kirsten's job
today was to
to make a lot of the 36 hour period
after which
uh matt hancock was given the green
light by downing street on friday
lunchtime the moment that he
uh resigned on on saturday uh evening
um that delay effectively in the
reshuffle was
thrown back in his face by bear by boris
johnson who pointed out well of course
when
kirsten had a reshuffle uh particularly
angela reyna that took quite a long time
and resulted in an angel arena being
promoted um but i think that kirsten's
defenders would point to a
you know quite a harrowing tale that he
brought up
uh and uh that was the one uh the story
of uh oliver bibby from uh uh
from unable to see a dying child who had
leukemia earlier this year and the
family
uh weren't able to see the 27 year old
and it was
apparently it was big in hospital was
like being trapped in prison
and in response to that uh boris johnson
i think
probably thinking he was getting back on
the front foot dismissed what kierstama
was saying as a
westminster bubble story i think it's
quite a lot of uh commentary at the
moment about whether or not that was
uh appropriate given the story that
kirstama uh was
telling the suffering of people miles
from women exactly and i think uh
but there is a question i think it was
probably a misjudgment by the prime
minister to do that there's an
interesting question about how much that
cuts through to the
uh to the public uh and how much they
noticed
that kind of backing back and forth and
the tone that the prime minister
adopted pretty characteristic for him
not necessarily to do that we've seen a
previous prime minister's questions
but the overall message of kierstama was
inconsistency
one rule for your friends another rule
for everyone else is having to
put up with these restrictions that's
right and there is a long charge sheet
for boris johnson when it comes to this
he pointed to pretty patel for example
who broke the ministerial code but was
kept in post the ministerial adviser
uh for interest it was the one that
ended up uh resigning plenty of
questions around other cabinet ministers
and yet they have stayed
in post uh in circumstances where i
would strongly suspect
previous prime ministers might have got
rid of them but
as it were the public have been making
their judgment as we go along on those
cases and haven't yet
uh cast against the prime minister we've
seen in opinion polls last month's
elections
new by-elections that come along
cheshire and american and and we've got
the
baton spend one tomorrow that these
issues aren't exercising the public
given that we've got a pandemic
coronavirus uh vaccine roll out and
uh and still economic support which uh
which is very popular with the public
although it has to be said to be
interesting to see what happens to
politics as that economic support is
withdrawn over the next few months and
interesting both sides of the
sectarian divide in northern ireland the
alliance party and the dep
asking questions about the high court
ruling which basically was a challenge
by the dup and allies saying that the
northern ireland protocol was against
the law
and that's been thrown out in the high
court in belfast although uh
ian pacey's junior still going further
and asking the prime minister to throw
it out effectively
yes and uh a defeat for the unionist but
in paisley trying to
to cling on to some of the language and
the judgment to suggest that
uh boris jones is breaking his
commitment um but we've got
let's go to the urgent question now this
is from labour's education spokesperson
kate green to gavin williamson
mr speaker i'm grateful to you for
granting the certain question
this government is absolutely focused on
returning society back to normal
as soon as possible and that includes in
our schools
colleges and right across the education
sector
as i have made clear throughout this
pandemic it is my top priority to keep
children in school and indeed as i speak
today
it is the case that millions of children
have been back in the classroom
since march the 8th learning with their
friends
and teachers i'm sure the house will
agree
that's exactly where they belong
the vast majority of schools are open
99.8 percent of state funded schools
were open on the 24th of june
benefiting children who have given up so
much during this pandemic
back in february the prime minister set
out an extensive
roadmap and that we need to continue to
be careful
now to complete this cautious but
irreversible road map to freedom
we understand the frustration of parents
and pupils who may feel
like that they're being asked to isolate
unnecessarily
as i have said throughout this pandemic
children
are best off in schools as we continue
with our educational recovery it is
vital that absence is minimized as far
as possible
and that children and young people are
attending school
so i'm looking carefully every day at
how we manage the balance between
safeguarding children's education
and reducing the transmission of the
virus because i know
that there are still too many children
having their education
disrupted no matter how good
remote education is that they're
receiving
the new health secretary and i have
already discussed these matters and i'm
working with him
across my department as well as with
scientists
and public health experts to take the
next steps
but as this house is aware some
restrictions remain in place in schools
what i want to see is these restrictions
including bubbles
removed as quickly as possible along
with
wider restrictions in society i do not
think it is acceptable that children
should face greater restrictions over
and above those
of wider society especially since they
have given
up so much to keep older generations
safe
over the last 18 months further steps
will be
taken to reduce the number of children
who have to ice
self-isolate including looking at the
outcomes of the daily contact testing
trial
as we consider a new model for keeping
children in schools and colleges
we constantly assess all available data
and we expect to be able to confirm
plans
to lift restrictions and bubbles as part
of step four
once that decision has been made we'll
issue guidance immediately to schools
i would once again like to put on for
record this government's sincere thanks
to all teachers
for their dedication and work at this
time
my commitment to the house and to the
children of britain is that
we open up wider society we will stick
as we open it up wide society up we'll
stick to the principle
that children's education and freedom
comes first
okay thank you for granting the urgent
question mr speaker data published
yesterday showed 375 000 children
were out of school last week because of
coronavirus
it's nine weeks until the new academic
year begins but we have no idea what the
secretary of state plans to keep them in
class
school leaders dread another last minute
announcement
they need time to put plans in place and
their staff also
desperately need a break over the summer
the secretary of state has briefed that
the bubbles policy will be replaced with
daily testing from september
will testing take place in schools and
if so what support will they receive to
do it
can you tell the house the results of
the pilots in schools using regular
testing instead of bubbles
what impact has this had on the number
of coronavirus cases in the school
community
and the number of hours children and
staff remain in class
and can he tell us why if he believes he
has a solution that will keep children
safely in the classroom
he's waiting until september what's he
doing now to keep children in school
before the summer holidays
time and again labour's called for
mitigations to keep
children learning including ventilation
and nightingale classrooms
why has this not happened can he clarify
why he abandoned the policy of masks in
schools when cases were rising
and masks were still required in shops
and outdoor spaces
indoor spaces will he share the
scientific evidence
that led to this decision can he confirm
that children who have to isolate over
the summer
and can't attend the holiday activities
and food programme
will still receive free meals and
finally mr speaker can you tell us when
he expects to receive
jcvi advice on vaccinating older
children
does he believe that they will begin
receiving the vaccine
before september mr speaker ministers
negligence in letting the delta variant
into our country is keeping hundreds of
thousands of children out of the
classroom
the secretary of state must act now or
make way for someone who will
yeah so state well thank you ever so
much mr speaker so in terms of daily
contact testing this is
something that we've been running trials
on
well public health england have been
running trails on we expect to
for them to report back to the
department for health and
social care and ourselves in the coming
weeks
but we are very clear that we want to
sort of action
to be taken and that is why we very much
want to see
the lifting of more restrictions and the
bubbles within schools
as part of the next step but as the
honourable lady and yourself mr speaker
will appreciate
that this is a decision that has to be
made
across government as part of the next
stage of our road map but with
course be informing schools and keeping
them
up to date as to that progress in plenty
of time before the start of the next
term
but let us not forget mr speaker is the
party opposite
is the party opposite that danes to give
advice i mean their advice was to
join the european union vaccine program
well where would that
have got us mr speaker the party
opposite that said it wouldn't be
possible for schools to be able to
deliver testing
right across all our schools and
colleges yet this is what we were able
to do
and actually is a party opposite that
opposed children going back
into the classroom and didn't actually
support this government's efforts
to ensure that children were able to get
their education at the earliest possible
stage
as every point the party opposite has
done everything that they can
to prostrate and stop the opportunities
of children being in
school select committee robert
um thank you mr speaker i thank my right
on a friend for what he's doing to try
and keep
schools open um but we have 300 000
children
being sent home in addition there are 93
500 children who are missing 50 to
school or more
as identified by the center for social
justice
this week in their heart and report we
are in danger
of creating a generation of ghost
children denied a proper chance to
climb the education ladder of
opportunity so will my right honourable
friend
update the guidance look to establish
mobile testing units for school as soon
as possible
even before september so as to stop the
need for children being sent home
and when he also set out a plan
galvanizing the forces of the department
local authorities and schools
as to how these hundred thousand ghost
children are going to be returned to
school properly
so that we can bring their education
back to life and we don't damage their
life chances for decades to come
so my right honourable friend raises the
importance issue of those children who
aren't attending schools
this is why we pull together react teams
which is a combination
of dfe
teams regional school commissioners
local authorities the police
as well as crucially schools themselves
in terms of being able to target
uh those uh children as long working
alongside the supporting families
initiative that is
uh led by mhclg my right honourable
friend will be aware that actually there
is already
extensive testing in schools in fact
there's been over
uh 50 million i think 57 million tests
have already been conducted in schools
and colleges across
the country so we already have a very
well established testing mechanism
but the next stage as we move to
step four of a robot is we want to see
the ability for schools to be able to
operate more freely
when it comes to the summer activities
we want all children to be able
to be uh be able to be part of that
whether that's for holiday activity and
food programs whether that is
whether that is the additional summer
schools that schools are laying on
and that is why as part of step four uh
we're looking at lifting those
restrictions and
lifting those bubbles that currently uh
schools
um have to sort of operate within that
guidance of and we're looking at doing
that at the very
earliest opportunity so children were
able to benefit through the summer
uh as a result of that let's go to barry
sherman
barely thank you thank you
mr speaker um can i say to the secretary
of state
will you stop this diva and delay
now i don't think that anyone in this
house
on education matters i think we're
united that there is a generation of
young children
that are missing have missed education
and will continue
to miss education and families
parents particularly want certainty they
want to know what the rules are
and what they can expect so they can
plan their everyday lives
and most of all all of us who care about
education
know that the summer holidays coming up
could be an opportunity for a vast
level of national volunteers working
with children
to give them that support they're going
to be vitally
missing because they've missed so much
school education come on
uh secretary of state take the lead do
something
positive imaginative and bold
uh well i thank the uh honorable
gentleman for his uh thoughts um we have
already
outlined uh and i'd if he had listened
to the question i had sort of
an answer to my uh right one friend the
member for harlow is that we're
very much looking towards uh lifting the
restrictions especially in terms of
bubbles as part of
the next step of the road map as the uh
honorable gentleman will be aware that
the government is going to
in the very near future announce the
next step of the road map and
it will be very much part of that and
that will be it's important that all the
actions right across government are
properly coordinated as part of a
process of easing restrictions right
across the country
let's go to bob blackmon bob thank you
very much
uh mr speaker and i'm delighted that the
government
prioritized the reopening of schools as
we ease
the lockdown and i congratulate my
writer or friend for all the efforts
he's made
to make sure that children return to
schools
and get in-person education as much as
possible
now clearly as we do so does he agree
with me
that rolling out regular testing will
ensure
that we stop the spread of the of the
virus
but also prevent children from
unnecessarily being sent home
and missing out on their education at
the same time
as making sure that the tests are
carried out
properly and appropriately
i absolutely agree with my honourable
friends and he'll
probably have seen the figures of over
50 billion tests already
conducted across schools and colleges
we're
very much uh aware that uh testing is uh
has been an important part of getting
schools reopened and we
continue to work with colleagues in the
department for health and social care
and track and trace
in order to ensure testing is available
which of course
it is available to all pupils and their
families as well